[Music]
have you ever dated about traveling
through time perhaps fast forward in the
centuries and seen the distant future
well time travel is possible and what's
more it's already been done meet Sergei
krikalev the greatest time traveler in
human history this Russian cosmonaut
holds the record for the most amount of
tyrants been orbiting our planet a total
of 803 days 9 hours and 39 minutes
during this stay in space he time
traveled into his own future by 0.02
seconds traveling at 17,500 miles an
hour he experienced an effect known as
time dilation and one day the same
effect might make significant time
travel to the future commonplace CY
moving faster through space affects
passage of time when to go back to the
1880s when two American scientists of
Medicine and Edward Morley were trying
to measure the effect of the earth
movement around the Sun on the speed of
light when a beam of light was moving in
the same direction as the earth they
expected the light to travel faster and
when the earth was moving the opposite
direction they expected it to go slower
but they found something very curious
the speed of light remained the same no
matter what the earth was doing two
decades later Albert Einstein was
thinking about the consequences of that
never changing speed of light and I was
his conclusions formulated in the theory
of special relativity to open the door
into the world of time travel
imagine a man named Jack standing in the
middle of a train carriage traveling as
30 speed Jack's board and starts
bouncing a ball up and down
what would Jill standing on the platform
see through the window as a train
whistles through well between Jack
dropping the ball and catching again gia
will have seen him move slightly further
down the track resulting in her seeing
the ball follow a triangular path this
means Jill sees the ball travel further
than Jack does in the same time period
and because speeds distance divided by
time
Jill actually sees the ball move faster
but what if Jack's bouncing ball is
replaced with two mirrors which bounce a
beam of light between them Jack still
sees the beam go up and down and geo
still sees the light beam travel a
longer distance except this time Jack
and gel cannot disagree on the speed
because the speed of light remains the
same than a watt and if the speed is the
same while the distance is different
this means the time taken will be
different as well thus time must ticket
different rates people moving relative
to each other
imagine that Jack and Jill had highly
accurate watches that they synchronize
before Jack boarded the train during the
experiment Jack and Jill would each see
their own watch ticking normally but if
they meet up again later to compare
watches less time whenever laps call
into Jack's watch balancing the fact
that Jill saw the light move further
this idea may sound crazy but like any
good scientific theory it can be tested
in the 1970s scientists boarded a plane
with some super accurate atomic clocks
that was synchronized with some others
left on the ground after the plane of
fun around the world the clocks on board
took a different time from those left
behind of course at the speed of trains
and planes the effect is minuscule but
the faster you go the more time dilates
the astronauts orbiting the earth 800
days it starts to add up
but what affects humans also affects
machines satellites of the global
positioning system are also hurtling
around the earth at thousands of miles
an hour so time dilation kicks in here
too in fact their speed causes the
atomic clocks on board to disagree with
clocks on the ground by 7 millionth of a
second daily left uncorrected this would
cause GPS to lose accuracy by a few
kilometers each day
so what does all this have to do with
time travel to the far distant future
well the faster you go the greater the
effect of time dilation if you can
travel really close to the speed of
light say 99.9999% on a round-trip
through space for what seemed to you
like 10 years you'd actually return to
earth around the Year 9,000 knows what
you'd see when you returned humanity
merge with machines extinct due to
climate change or asteroid impact or
inhabiting a permanent colony on Mars
but the trouble is that getting heavy
things like people not to mention
spaceships up to such speeds requires
unimaginable amount of energy it already
takes enormous particle accelerators of
a Large Hadron Collider to accelerate
tiny subatomic particles to close the
light speed but one day if we can
develop the tools accelerate ourselves
to similar speeds then we may regularly
send time travel into the future bring
with them tales of a long-forgotten past
[Music]
you